Forgotten History - The First Movie and the
Scientific Question It Sought to Answer
The first films were little more than what
we would consider short clips, a boxer throwing
a single punch or train arriving at a station–
the type of scenes that today you might only
see in the form of animated gifs.
While popular perception is that movies got
their start around the early twentieth century,
the real seed that grew into the film industry
came a few decades before that in Eadweard
Muybridge’s truly revolutionary 1878 “Horse
in Motion.”
While it and hundreds of subsequent similar
works Muybridge filmed wowed audiences the
world over, this first film was not created
to entertain, but to answer a question.
For centuries, artists, horse enthusiasts
and scientists alike had wondered: Do all
four of a horse’s hooves leave the ground
in mid gallop?
While this might seem silly and obvious to
us today, at the time it was not so.
In fact, if you look at artists’ depictions
of horses galloping throughout history up
to Muybridge’s “Horse in Motion,” they
almost universally depict the horse in gallop
incorrectly.
The problem, of course, was that this question
could not be answered by the naked eye.
And leading up to the momentous “Horse in
Motion,” photographic technology of the
day wasn’t up to the task of clearly capturing
a horse galloping.
Enter Leland Stanford, who wanted to answer
this question and, in the process, learn as
much as possible about how horses run in order
to potentially improve the performance of
his race horses.
For a little background on the man, while
today many have only heard of him because
of the University he helped found (in homage
to his son who died at 16), by today’s standards,
Leland Stanford was somewhat corrupt.
He initially made his fortune by selling mining
equipment to those who came west for the California
Gold Rush.
He then invested a significant portion of
this money into the California Central Pacific
Railroad, becoming one of the “Big Four”
to financially spur the success of the iconic
railway.
At the same time (and perhaps because of it),
he was elected California’s governor.
Using the office to enrich himself and his
fellow investors further, he secured massive
state investment and land grants for the railroad
project.
He became ludicrously wealthy (at his peak
having a net worth of about $1.5 billion in
today’s dollars), owned several mansions,
vineyards and a racetrack in Palo Alto.
Speaking of this race track, after the completion
of the railroad, horses became Stanford’s
obsession.
According to George T. Clark’s biography
Leland Stanford, it was actually Stanford’s
doctor’s orders that he take on supposedly
stress free hobbies like horse rearing and
racing.
Because he apparently couldn’t do anything
half-speed, Stanford wanted to revolutionize
how trainers worked with racing horses.
In order to do this, he realized he needed
to figure out how horses ran – in the process
answering the age old question.
So, he turned to the best and most innovator
photographer in San Francisco, Eadweard Muybridge.
Born in England in 1830, Muybridge moved to
the United States and became a bookseller
around 1852.
Ultimately ending up in California, he was
moderately successful at this venture and
by the age of 30 decided he was ready for
something else.
He announced in the paper in 1860:
I have this day sold to my brother Thomas
S. Muybridge my entire stock of books, engravings,
etc.
I shall leave for New York, London, Berlin,
Paris, Rome, and Vienna, etc…
However, on his way to start his grand adventure,
a fateful stagecoach crash in Texas resulted
in Muybridge being ejected from the coach,
at which point he smacked his head against
a rock, causing severe brain trauma.
When he awoke in a hospital some 150 miles
away, he noted that, “each eye formed an
individual impression so that looking at you,
for instance, I could see another man sitting
by your side.”
After several months, he recovered enough
to return to England, but did not go on the
grand tour he’d previously planned, instead
spending the next six years in his native
land.
While the accident may have left him with
permanent brain damage, it also set the stage
for the career that would make him world famous.
You see, at some point during his lengthy
recovery period, according to Muybridge, one
of his physicians suggested he take up the
relatively new field of photography.
Fast forward to 1872 and Muybridge was one
of the leading photographers in the world,
being vaulted to that world-wide fame after
shooting over 200 stunningly clear shots of
Yosemite Valley in 1868.
(An easy thing to do today, but in his time
an amazing achievement; beyond being exceptionally
difficult to capture such shots with any clarity
due to long exposure times, this also required
him to trek around the wilderness for several
months carrying all the equipment he’d need
to both take and develop the photos on the
spot.
Once a location was chosen, he’d then have
to wait for just the right lighting and weather
conditions that would allow him to take the
expansive shots without blurring.)
Wanting the best, as previously noted, Stanford
approached Muybridge about helping him figure
out how exactly a horse runs.
Despite Stanford’s suggestion that they
could do this by combining multiple real-time
photos in succession, Muybridge declared the
task impossible.
The available technology of the day wouldn’t
allow it; exposure times were typically on
the order of 15-60 seconds, which was completely
unsuitable for capturing any motion whatsoever.
Money talks, however, and Stanford was ultimately
able to convince Muybridge to take on the
project via offering him what ended up being
more or less an open ended budget.
While the pair made significant progress on
this front over the next two years, including
managing to capture a very blurry image that
seemed to show a horse galloping with all
four legs in the air, in 1874 the project
was interrupted because Muybridge was arrested
for murder- a crime he happily confessed to.
wifeYou see, two years earlier he married
the 21-year-old (and 20 years his junior)
Flora Stone.
(When he originally met Stone, she was already
married, with Muybridge paying for her divorce.)
Back to 1874, on April 15th of that year she
bore a son, Floredo Helios Muybridge.
Not long after the birth of the child, Muybridge
went to pay the midwife who delivered the
boy, Susan Smith.
While there, Muybridge discovered a photograph
of his son.
On the back, it said “Little Harry” in
his wife’s handwriting…
When Muybridge saw this, he went ballistic.
Under extreme duress, the midwife confessed
to Muybridge that Flora and one Major Harry
Larkyns were having an affair.
The midwife later recounted what happened
next, “When I told Muybridge of the affair,
he cried like a baby…”
He then asked her, “Who’s baby is that,
mine or Larkyns?”
She replied, “I do not know.”
She then told him she had seen his wife “on
the bed with her clothes down to her waist
and Larkyns sat on the bedside…”
Muybridge did not take the news well.
“In great agony of mind, he wandered about.
My opinion is when he left me he was insane.”
Directly after leaving the midwife, Muybridge
went home and collected his revolver.
He then took a train and then a horse and
carriage to Larkyns’ home.
Arriving several hours after learning of the
affair, Muybridge knocked on the door.
According to the February 4, 1875 edition
of the San Francisco Chronicle, when Larkyns
answered the door, Muybridge said, “I am
Muybridge and this is a message from my wife,”
at which point he pulled out his gun and shot
Larkyns in the chest, killing him.
Muybridge was subsequently arrested and, a
few months later, put on trial for murder.
At no point did he deny killing Larkyns, nor
did he himself claim he had been driven insane
when he killed him.
Quite the contrary, in fact; he felt he was
justified in the act.
In an interview with the San Francisco Chronicle
while in prison, Muybridge described his relationships
and motivations,
We never had any trouble to speak of.
We sometimes had little disputes about money
matters, but they were not serious.
I was always a man of very simple tastes and
few wants, and I did not spend much money.
What I had left over after paying my little
expenses, I gave to her, but she was always
wanting more.
I could never see that she had bought anything
with it to speak of or imagine what she did
with it.
We sometimes had little spats about money,
but nothing serious…
I loved the woman with all my heart and soul.
And the revelation of her infidelity was a
cruel frustrating blow to me.
Since the shooting I’ve been told many things
to which I was previously blind.
Friends whom I should have expected to inform
me when they saw how I was being deceived
have now told me all.
I did not desire to see her again.
They may ransack my record as much as they
please, and I defy them to bring anything
against me.
I have no fear of the result.
I feel that I was justified in what I did
and that all right minded people would justify
my action.
Of course, the law is the law and this sort
of vigilantism tends to not hold up well when
placed in the crucible of organized justice.
Luckily for Muybridge, the enormously wealthy
Leland Stanford still wanted his question
answered and needed Muybridge to do it.
Thus, Stanford hired a team of lawyers to
defend him, including C.H. King and W.W.
Pendegast.
They outlined their defense in their opening
remarks on February 3, 1875:
We claim a verdict both on the ground of justifiable
homicide and insanity.
We shall prove that years ago, the prisoner
was thrown from a stage, receiving a concussion
of the brain, which turned his hair from black
to gray in three days, and has never been
the same since.
Ultimately the jury was not convinced that
Muybridge had been insane, not the least of
which because, as previously noted, in public
comments he himself didn’t seem inclined
towards the notion (though he never testified
officially in the case).
However, while the judge explicitly told the
jury that killing a man for having an affair
with one’s wife was by no means justifiable
murder as far as the law was concerned, the
jury didn’t agree.
As noted in a contemporary report in the San
Francisco Chronicle,
The jury discarded entirely the theory of
insanity, and meeting the case on the bare
issue left, acquitted the defended on the
ground that he was justified in killing Larkyns
for seducing his wife.
This was directly contrary to the charge of
the Judge, but the jury do not mince the matter,
or attempt to excuse the verdict.
They say that if their verdict was not in
accord with the law of the books, it is with
the law of human nature; that, in short, under
similar circumstances they would have done
as Muybridge did, and they could not conscientiously
punish him for doing that they would have
done themselves.
In the aftermath of the murder, Muybridge’s
wife would divorce him, but she became ill
and died about nine months after Muybridge
killed her lover.
As for Florado, with his mother no longer
alive to care for him (and his supposed father
dead at the hands of Muybridge), Muybridge
unceremoniously put the poor boy in an orphanage,
though he did provide for his financial needs.
(It was later noted that the child grew up
to slightly resemble Muybridge, perhaps indicating
that he had indeed been his son and not Harry
Larkyns’ as Muybridge and his wife had thought.
Florado himself seems to have been inclined
towards the notion as when he died at the
age of 70 after being hit by a car, his tombstone
stated: “Florado Helios Muybridge, Apr.
16, 1874 – Feb. 2, 1944, Son of photographer
Eadweard James Muybridge”.)
Whatever the case, as for Muybridge, he traveled
throughout South America for about a year
before returning in 1876 to begin working
with Stanford again.
With Stanford’s ample resources in hand
(the project ultimately costing about $50,000
or $1.14 million today), Muybridge invented
a new rapid shutter mechanism and more sensitive
chemicals allowing for quick, clear exposure
of a galloping horse.
And so it was that after many failed experiments
and ultimately some successful test runs that
revealed the answer clearly, on June 19, 1878,
Muybridge and Stanford invited the press to
watch them officially capture something that
would change the way we looked at the world.
On one side of the track was a white shed
filled with a dozen cameras, each containing
two lenses to make two separate exposures
per camera (in case one didn’t come out
right).
On the other side was a white background to
increase contrast.
On the track itself was a series of 12 tripwires
spaced approximately 20-21 inches (30 cm)
apart, with each connected to the cameras’
shutter mechanism.
Press surrounded the track.
At the far end, master trainer Charles Marvin
had the reins of one of Stanford’s race
horses.
With a gun blast, the horse took off.
In less than half a second after she had reached
the first trip-wire, the horse had tripped
all 12 of them, setting up a succession of
dropping shutters.
Time at this point was critical as the shots
just taken had to be processed while the negatives
were still moist, with only around 10-20 minutes
to develop the 24 total plates after taking
the shots.
Once Muybridge had done this in his little
mobile development studio, he put the pictures
out for the gathered people to see.
It should be noted here that beyond the necessity
to develop the shots right away, it was particularly
critical for the press to see him do this.
You see, some past test photos Muybridge had
captured of a horse in full gallop had been
largely dismissed by many in the press as
forgeries, with some even going so far as
to mock his supposed shots in cartoon caricatures.
Many people simply refused to believe that
it was actually possible to take a clear photo
of a galloping horse.
Thus, Muybridge wanted the journalists to
see the horse galloping live and see him both
take the shots of it and develop the photos
in front of them so there would be no doubt
of their accuracy and his accomplishment.
As for the pictures themselves, they were
stunningly clear, with one witness to the
event noting you could even see “the threadlike
tip of Mr. Marvin’s whip… in each negative.”
Ultimately rough woodcuttings were made so
that the photos could be transferred into
newspapers for the public to see, with the
following result:The_Horse_in_Motion_high_resWhat
was revealed in the succession of photo proofs
is that, yes, horses did basically “fly”
through the air when galloping, as, at one
point, all four of their hooves did leave
the ground.
What’s more, this happened when their hooves
were pointed inward as opposed to outward
like most speculated and what the majority
of artists up to this point had portrayed
when showing horses galloping.
Some famed artists of the day took the news
well, even subsequently contacting Muybridge
to help them make their future works depicting
horses more accurate.
However, as was noted in the press, Muybridge’s
photos seemingly made a mockery of pretty
much all past artworks depicting horses moving.
So it’s perhaps not surprise that some artists,
such as famed sculptor Auguste Rodin (best
known today for his “The Thinker” sculpture),
went the other way, noting, “It is the artist
who is truthful and it is photography which
lies, for in reality time does not stop.”
Needless to say, Muybridge and Stanford’s
stunt was a rousing success.
But this was just the beginning.
Muybridge now had a way to film things in
natural motion.
He quickly improved the technology, including
inventing an electromagnetic timer to control
the shutters instead of trip-wires (allowing
for a shutter speed of 1/1000th of a second).
Beyond this, he invented what was more or
less the first movie projector in his zoopraxiscope,
showing the first film of “The Horse in
Motion” in the fall of 1879 to Stanford
and a select group.
As one reported noted of this first movie
screening, “Nothing was wanting but the
clatter of hoofs upon the turf and the occasional
breath of steam to make the spectator believe
he had before him the flesh and blood steeds.”
There was a problem in all this though.
Initially Stanford and Muybridge seemed the
best of friends and happy to credit the other
for their respective contributions in this
revolution of art and science- Stanford provided
the funds, focus, and staff, and Muybridge
did the inventing and capturing of the historic
images.
This mutual credit would all change, however,
with the publishing of a book by one of Stanford’s
friends, Dr. J.B.D.
Stillman, titled The Horse in Motion, in 1882.
In it, the aptly named Stillman would show
around 100 drawings copied from Muybridge’s
photos, but without crediting Muybridge.
In fact, Muybridge was only mentioned in passing
in the book as an employee of Stanford’s.
This was despite the fact that the book was
explicitly “Executed and Published Under
the Auspices of Leland Stanford” who knew
well Muybridge’s real contributions.
Beyond being offended at credit not being
given, this also cost Muybridge a prestigious
job and a fair amount of his reputation, at
least initially, in his homeland.
After witnessing several such films Muybridge
had subsequently made in a lecture he gave
in Britain, the British Royal Society of Arts
offered him a rather lucrative contract to
film other animals and people in motion for
academic study.
But when the book came out with no real mention
of Muybridge, the Royal Society retracted
their offer, thinking Muybridge was lying
about his contributions in the project.
Not only that, but they also accused him of
being a plagiarist.
An academic paper Muybridge was attempting
to get published on the motion of horses mirrored
on several points what was written in Stillman’s
book, but with no credit given to Stillman.
Of course, the fact was that the work by Muybridge
had formed the bases for Dr. Stillman’s
notes in the book, not the other way around
as the Royal Society now assumed.
Muybridge was devastated, lamenting, “The
doors of the Royal Society were thus closed
against me and my promising career in London
was brought to a disastrous close.”
Muybridge would go on to not only sue the
publisher of the book, but Stanford himself,
thinking Stanford was intentionally trying
to downplay Muybridge’s contributions to
take all the credit himself, as so many who
financed inventors have done before.
Ultimately Muybridge lost the lawsuits, but
by this time the University of Pennsylvania,
who did not doubt Muybridge’s work, offered
to fund him in filming everything from birds
in flight to nude men and women doing various
things like carrying buckets, going up and
down stairs, hitting baseballs, rowing boats,
dancing, etc.
(You can see some of these short films here,
here, and here.)
The point of all this, at least as far as
the University was concerned, was to study
various complex body movements in slow motion.
As for Muybridge, while he publicly lauded
the scientific merit of his work, he more
revelled in the art of it all, and rightly
recognized how his work would influence artists
to come.
Beyond the more obvious examples, with several
famed paintings in the subsequent decades
just putting their own spin on one of Muybridge’s
stills, his books could be found on the desks
of many of the early animators in Hollywood
as they tried to accurately depict motion.
On top of this, Muybridge’s idea of what
is now sometimes called “bullet-time”
has been popular throughout the history of
cinema, perhaps best depicted today in the
original Matrix film.
Long before that film (and many others before
and since) used the exact technique, however,
Muybridge was first- setting up a series of
cameras in a semi-circle around subjects,
timed to take pictures as they moved.
In one such case, a nude Muybridge can be
seen swinging a pic-axe.
In the end, Muybridge, who viewed himself
as an artist rather than a scientist, ultimately
made his money using his new technology to
aid science while hoping to influence art.
However, within a couple decades, the likes
of the Lumière brothers and Thomas Edison
(the latter of which who would consult with
Muybridge) would eclipse his work with their
own versions of this new type of technology,
advancing the field from something akin to
short animated gifs to lengthy productions.
This was an advancement Muybridge foresaw
and more, describing the future of what would
become cinema,
In the not too distant future, instruments
will be constructed that will not only reproduce
visible actions simultaneously with audible
words, but an entire opera, with the gestures,
facial expressions, and songs of the performers,
with all the accompanying music, will be recorded
and reproduced by an apparatus combining the
principles of the zoopraxiscope and the phonograph,
for the instruction and entertainment of an
audience long after the original participants
have passed away.
Despite his life’s work being largely in
the public eye, beyond initially having his
accomplishments somewhat usurped by Stanford
and Stillman, Muybridge’s role as one of
the father’s of film would be largely forgotten
by popular history.
To add insult to injury, after he died in
1904, even his own tombstone has his name
misspelled, inscribed “Eadweard Maybridge”.
Stanford sunk a huge percentage of his fortune,
about $40 million (a little over a billion
dollars today), into creating the notable
Leland Stanford Junior University (commonly
called just “Stanford,” though it still
officially retains its original name).
As previously mentioned, this university was
named after his son who contracted typhoid
fever shortly before his 16th birthday.
He ultimately died of the condition shortly
thereafter in 1884.